it'll be vince velasquez making his
third turn in the rotation for the
phillies and he will be out there
tonight without bryce harper behind him
kane back in there
last appeared in the contest on the 13th
of april
on one pitch to lorenzo swinging a high
drive center field wow welcome back
lorenzo kane
lorenzo kane has returned with a lean
back jack
wow that's a return
home run number three i'd say he's
wheeling enable
wow
welcome back lorenzo
one nothing brewers
that's as far balls we've seen lorenzo
cain hit in four years as a member of
the brewers 446.
every bit of 446.
brewers also welcoming christian yelich
back to the lineup he's in left field
batting third and the payoff pitch
coming and that is stung into left
center field a base hit yeah i think
kanan yelled they seemed to be all right
yeah
picking up right where he left off
not only hitting it hard on a high
fastball but taking it into left center
and dan vogelbach is coming up
batting 167 with a couple of homers the
pitch swung on and popped up
straight up and it looks like bowman
gregorius left side now dd calls off
boom he'll make the catch
and
no further damage done
the home run by kane puts the brewers on
top two hits two left we'll go to the
bottom of the first it's milwaukee one
and the phillies coming up tonight it
will be right-hander adrian hauser on
the mound he's two and two with a 3.65
earned run average
here's
jt rilmuto
and a high fly ball to deep left field
into the knights
a two-run second deck home run for jt
real muto
and the phillies have taken the lead
that's one of the farthest balls you'll
see hit to left field
it's his third home run of the season
and he crushed it
bringing colton wong to the plate wong
with the former cardinal
here's the pitch
and wong swings and lines one pretty
deep to left joyce go back though has it
measured he'll make the catch actually
went back and then had to come in a step
to make the grab
and that'll do it
for the brewers no runs on a lead off
double they leave the man stranded at
third we're going to the bottom of the
second it's 2-1 phillies
roman quinn the hitter
fly ball left center field slicing away
from kane and it's going to get past him
and one hop the wall it goes off the tip
of his glove a runo score quinn is
flying into third and he's there sliding
so now vince velasquez
who bats with the infield in and a
runner at third
and the o2
swinging a bouncer right side shaw with
a backhand or vogelbach with a backhand
pick but his
only play is going to be the first he
thought about home but quinn is just too
fast and vince velasquez gets the rbi as
he gets the bat on the ball and
gives the phillies a 4-1 lead took the
words right out of my mouth he made
contact put the ball in play
vogel back
now bats with two on
the pitch runners go and the pitch is
bounced to third alec bombs got it on
one hop throws across to get vogel back
[Applause]
and vince velasquez headed back to the
dugout with a three-run lead no runs one
hit two left we're going to the bottom
of the third four to one
phillies
there's hauser the pitcher
call strike three five strikeouts for
velasquez and a one two three fourth
inning
and there's the first one two three
inning of the night for vince velasquez
as they go in order
in their half of the fourth will go to
the bottom of the fourth phillies four
in the brewers one
top of the order here for the brewers
colton wong against vince velazquez
swing and a miss he got it with a 94
mile an hour fastball six strikeouts for
velasquez
two up two down here's yelich and the
pitch swinging the ground ball back at
vince he's got it flips underhand at
first and there's a quick inning
for vince who gives yella to pat on the
butt on the way by in the first base
line
going to the bottom of the fifth
philly's leading 4-1
and turn the line up over one more time
to matt joyce he's bounced to second
base twice three and two here comes
hauser
swaying and a fly ball well hit left
center yelich
and kane it'll be yelich making the call
in the catch in the gap
for the final out of the inning on to
the sixth in philadelphia it's four to
one
phillies they'll go back
as uh over two
volkl back waiting and the 2-2 on the
way swinging a bouncer to first miller
backs up takes the second hop on a
backhand flips it to vince
who covers in plenty of time and the
side is retired it is ten straight
brewers down in order against vince
velasquez
who goes six innings tonight and we're
headed to the bottom of the sixth he's
got the lead four 4-1
4-1 ball game
and you've got bohm coming up here
two-and-oh on bowm got to be careful
here tons of power
from baum
to oh coming
swinging a ground ball sharply hit but
right at colton wong bobbles it picks it
up throws the first just in time
[Applause]
wong in that transfer got a little quick
able to pick it up and
get the out at first base no damage done
nice outing from
adrian hauser tonight six strong we go
to the seventh brewers looking for some
runs and now two are on
with joyce coming to the plate
long looking for perdomo who's taking
his time here
looks at second the 3-2
call third strike
96 on the outside part of the plate
joyce didn't like it neither did the
crowd
perdomo strikes out the side with a base
hitting a walk in there as well the
philly strand a pair
and he's out of the game that joyce has
been ejected from the game
and the go ahead run
at the plate
shaw one for five on the season with the
bases loaded
1-1
swinging a fly ball hit to center quinn
back nearing the warning track makes the
catch tagging
and scoring is colton wong moving to
third
is lorenzo kane it's a 4-2 game on a
sacrifice fly
by travis shaw
rbi number 22 for travis
now the brewers have chances for more
runs with garcia at the plate 1-1 on
garcia
here's the pitch
swinging a bouncer hit towards short
could be two gregorius the second one on
the first not in time garcia beats it
out brewers get a run
it's four to three
alec baum
runner at second base a huge run out
there for the phillies
kicks and throws struck him out with a
slider melee blocks tags balm inning
over
a double by gregorius with two outs goes
for not for philadelphia
well lorenzo kane started this night
with a home run in the first inning put
the brewers up one to nothing
now he's got a chance to put the brewers
back on top
base hit here would give him the lead
check swing did he go yes he did says
hunter wendell set and the ball game
is finally over